let's do some audience questions a Tina
wrote in Tina said hey guys are there
certain things that should not be joked
about ever like for example rape murder
terrorist attacks etc so I have to
answer to this my literal answer is no
there are not certain things that should
be on a sort of list where one can never
ever make a joke about it it comes down
to sort of cultural and situational
awareness we can all imagine situations
we're making jokes about something like
a car accident could be seen as
incredibly disturbing upsetting and
offensive to people and also we all
probably know if we've watched anything
from Saturday Night Live to a comedy
show it's movies that there are jokes
made about murder terrorist attacks and
rape which because of the context are
not seen as so offensive so I think it's
much more about the individual situation
definitely you're also just able to say
things as a joke that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to get away with so I
mean if you were trying to comment on a
terrorist attack i mean we sometimes
have these policies where you should
wait a certain amount of time like a
virus attack again soon yeah I'm some
you know made ten years is the right
amount of time but some things you
should be wary of it and you may face
the consequences but I think for the
most part you should be able to joke
about anything it also depends who
you're around right i mean it's very
different if you have someone like for
example the president of the united
states at a diplomatic meeting with the
leader of another country a joke made in
that situation by the President of the
United States is going to be different
than something that someone says in
front of their family at thanksgiving
dinner versus something you say in
private to your significant other and
that again there's this some people like
to talk about how words have only an
objective meaning and context doesn't
matter that couldn't be more insane i
mean we all know that context really
does matter in the sort of linguistic
sense but it also matters in terms of
the social context and the cultural
context and there's no question about it
and this is a totally separate
from this idea of are certain people
allowed to use phrases or insults based
on their identity I'm not even talking
about that and different people who
watch the show I know disagree about
whether for example the n-word is ok to
use or not ok to use depending on your
whether black but whether you're black
or not I'm not even talking about that
I'm talking really specifically about
what Tina asked here I think that any
list of topics that are off-limits for
jokes it's problematic and I think that
that stifles all sorts of very very
creative and in many ways sometimes when
you're able to joke about serious things
in a particular way right not in a way
that D values are ridicule someone's
experience necessarily or is insulting
but joking about serious things can help
both victims and involved individuals
and observers move beyond something
which might be a horrible thing
absolutely so it's not really about
what's allowed and what's not allowed
but rather what's in good taste or not
yeah and there's certain things still
that society considers to be off-limits
for example even just a couple weeks ago
million opolis had his career basically
taking down for the time being because
he made a joke about pedophilia and I
mean we're colluding to it being less
serious than some might think I guess
yeah and he was abused in his past so
maybe he used humor as a vehicle to try
to overcome that yeah but you're still
playing with fire and you have to be
aware of what the consequences could
possibly be so Tina no there are no
things that should objectively be on
some list of topics never to be joked
about but use common sense